members before the commencement of the
meeting I need to read the emergency
evacuation announcement all right before
the commencement of the meeting I need
to read the emergency evacuation
announcement should we record should we
be required to evacuate the building
would you please leave the building via
the nearest available exit to the
chamber our assembly point will be in a
public car park at the side of the Civic
suite please don't please do not delay
your evacuation to collect any
belongings please don't do not return to
the building until given permission to
do so by council staff and please note
that this meeting will be audio recorded
members please be upstanding to receive
a chairman the Chairman's chaplain and
the managing director
good evening ladies and gentlemen let us
pray dear Lord as we gather together we
praise you for this day and your purpose
for it
we set our agendas as we sit in your
presence recalibrate our intentions and
refocus our hearts your will for our
lives that does not always reflect our
plans change them to reflect your will
so we thank you for every seat that has
been filled here for each mind and heart
that fills the presence of this room we
thank you only you know what we are to
set out to accomplish tonight only you
can see in perfect detail the end of
every beginning nothing is ever in vain
for even mistakes and missteps are used
for good the gracious Lord would you
bless this meeting we ask be with all
those presents helping them to come to a
common mind and to be ready to make
every moment count Jesus's name we ask
all of these things
krei cattle thank you
right the minutes of the I beg your
pardon
thank you apologies for rare counselor
Cooper yeah so Cooper thank you are
there any others now very good minutes
of the meeting held on the 17th of July
2018 are they agreed members are there
any declarations of interest yes
chairman just in case a non-pecuniary
about item 13 as my daughter has a horse
and we may be discussing something
that's all thank you thank you yes thank
you
Thank You chairman same item nine item
12
you know pecuniary interest thank you so
chairman eats actually item number 13
its virtue of my employment item 12
no item 13 motors my my era sorry
chairman thank you
item four sounds amount sment
announcements from the chairman leader
or head of paid service I don't think
there are none I will merely mention
that I have enjoyed enormously a number
of engagements on behalf of the council
and on behalf of the residents of this
district I won't go through them all
because you have seen them in the
members put it in and I hoped we were to
serve you in this similar manner over
the next few months castle campbell
thank you very much chairman it was
interesting to note through you chairman
that in the Daily Mail Rochford district
was found to be the 10th happiest place
to be in the country and I think that's
worthy of note chairman worthy of
putting in the minutes I think we're a
reasonably happy bunch here anyway but
it's nice to know that at least we're
considered for something and this is not
just in England this is in the country I
think they were two places in Northern
Ireland actually that were up there as
well so you know let's let's hope we can
keep it that way
and I think we're trying to do our best
to help all the others but it's it's
something that said something for where
we leave that we want to keep it that
way
thank you Jim thank you very much public
questions and member questions on notice
there are none business from the last
council meeting
there's none item 7 to note the minutes
of executive and committee meetings held
between the period 9th July to 19th
October 2018 as listed those noted
members item 8 to consider any reports
from the executive and committees
Council can I invite the counts for
sparing - yes thank you chairman what I
think the the report that has been
submitted and I'm sure members have read
is very concise very exact I think
members of the
planning policy subcommittee had every
opportunity to answer any questions of
the officers who to the best of my
knowledge answered everything very
professionally very concisely and I have
no hesitation in recommending the items
that are recommended for approval to
full Council Chairman yes thank you it's
very comprehensive report obviously but
there is something that does valve
concern me about the report we've got a
lot of indications in the report that
there are going to be considerable costs
in section 1 3 there are discussions
going on about costs we have resource in
costs and issues consultation costs in
appendix two three point three there is
no point within the report anything
indication indicating a framework for
costs here one of the reasons being
while bringing this out is because we
are on the JSP can be joining with other
councils there will no doubt at some
point the reports produced and as we all
know as members we have these reports
produced to us and they in some cases
are ludicrously expensive one of the
things that concerns me in a time when
we are very mindful of costs there is
not even a framework of how costs will
be allocated between the various
councils under the JSP and so I'm
flagging that up as quite a concern
thank you
having ticket chairman I think as we've
recognized it's been mentioned I think I
need to sort of draw the attention of
the member to five point one where it
says I think the and we're talking here
about the the statement of community
involvement that the costs will be
involved in can be met from existing
budget provision so it's actually
already accounted for as far as this
particular agenda item is concerned and
that's what we're discussing at this
particular meeting thank you cheering no
no mr. Stratton wants to elaborate on
that
Thank You chairman but do you think lung
cancer Eve does raise the court I raised
it myself during the meeting and I think
one point three refers to some of the
comments I made but I do think it's a
very good point in the wearing we're
actually been asked to a proof of
consultation with actually not knowing
how much the costs are it may well be
being met from existing budget
provisions but there is no indication of
the cost for what we were asking to do
here Thank You chairman Harkin I can
only reiterate the point that's been
made that the cost of the consultation
exercise can be met from existing
existing resources there is a fairly
substantial fund that is available to
the the planning policy team within the
budget as of now Thank You Terry surely
if it's in the budget we know how much
it's going to cost so why have we got
nothing in our report Germany if this is
what is needed and I'm sure officers
will be able to produce these figures
should they be required in future but as
far as I understand it and an office
it's made it very clear we have to
produce some of these reports they have
to be substantiated and somewhere along
the line we're gonna have to find the
resources for it now I'm pretty sure if
mr. Scranton says it's already catered
for in the budget then it will be
catered for in the budget
Thank You chair perhaps the the leader
could inform us what is currently
happening with regards to the memorandum
of understanding and the joint strategic
plan in respects of how this will
benefit the residents and do we know how
how our employees are supporting this
infrastructure Thank You chairman thank
you for the question
it's interesting actually because I
think it's a it's what we're doing
actually within the South of Essex is
quite innovative in as much as we're all
working together we're working together
to a common aim which is to actually
combine our plans to make sure that they
all marry up with each other and take
forward something that we can give to
government so we can actually obtain
some of the infrastructure and it indeed
helped with some of the infrastructure
deficit that we already have now one of
the things that we get when we are
arranged to develop areas is to say well
the infrastructure is not going and I'm
not just talking about roads I'm talking
about hospitals dentists schools you
name it and of course one of the things
that I can say and I think it's already
been mentioned is that we are liaising
with our members of parliament all of
whom I think are absolutely in line with
what we're doing because if we can get
this infrastructure investment coming
forward then indeed it will benefit
everybody who lives in our district and
indeed everybody who lives and/or works
within the South of Essex and that's
quite a considerable number of people of
course we're working across the South of
Essex and with our colleagues in Essex
County Council as well and I know that
the air employees have already been
lobbying the ministers about how we can
actually take this forward of course
we've got no solid plans at the moment
where we were still discussing and of
course it's it's one of those things a
bit of a bum fight as to what you
actually get in the end but going
forward I think it's it's an interview
plan that hopefully will come forward it
will be an overarching plan that we
look at all of the littler plans that
are coming forward from all of the areas
we do have some areas that are having
some difficulties we know that both
castle but Castle Point Basildon and
indeed brink would have had problems
with their local plans but hopefully
this will actually help them overcome
some of those problems because we can
actually work together and indeed get
that infrastructure in so they can
actually develop their plans properly so
I think it's a really good thing coming
forward and I think we should give it
every effort that we can we've already
got I think it's about eight hundred
thousand is it from government yeah to
actually do this so that shows you the
government is actually investing in what
we're doing and sees that we're actually
doing something that will be a benefit
to us all that's right across South s of
course so going forward
I think it's going to be something that
we really need to invest in and make
sure that we get the best use of for
Oxford and I really am very keen to do
that
Thank You chip Thank You chairman just a
couple of points by Michael on from our
leader yeah I don't disagree with him at
all that it's talking to other
authorities and be eyes with them is a
very good idea and we should do it or
hesitate to say that it could work well
I know this has been used in the north
of the county maybe slightly differently
where a number of authorities have
combined together with Essex and their
garden I'll call that city because I
think it's 24,000 houses in it was being
thrown out by the specter so it doesn't
always work well so I think we have to
be very careful how it works in our case
and I'm sure it will work better in the
south of the county than the north so
far I'm glad he raised the eight hundred
thousand pounds because I think perhaps
that goes back to the one of the points
councillor Eve was has made and I've
made in the past and at the planning
policy subcommittee is that yes where
our grants received for around eight
hundred thousand pound I think it might
be there's two grants I think it might
be slightly more now but we this money
is going for consultation somewhere and
for planning somewhere but we seem to
have failed to ask for any money within
these grants and I think perhaps we
should
game and when girls are being applied
for by or through a seller we should be
asking for funding for ourselves for
some of the consultations we should be
undertaking thank you
like Jim a lot of questions for our
deputy leader I understand there is a
launch taking place in December to do
with the a12 7 economical corridor is
there any further information on this
please thank chairman it gives me an
opportunity to tremendous but strictly
speaking it's in my role as County
counselor
we are putting together a task force
looking at the a12 7 economic corridor
which takes the a12 7 as its center
spine and ranges from in the south the
River Thames and in the north the river
crouch and it's the whole of the a12 7
right from galas corner right through to
cukoo corner we're working with all of
the councillors along the corridor
including therapy and South End we're
putting things together we've got em MP
support and we're looking to perhaps
hold a launch of this at South Indian
port somewhere around about the
beginning of December haven't got a
couple of dates in mind but with not
being confirmed as if yet so once those
dates become available I will let you
know further or more about it but if any
councillor or any member wishes to talk
to me after the meeting I'd I'd be only
too happy to fill them in with some more
of the detail
but the council resolves that the draft
addendum or we'll call that a tender
shall we - the adopted statement of
community involvement at appendices a B
and C to the officers report be
consulted on for four weeks is that
agreed members
the second recommendation at paragraph
four on page 81 - are there any members
wish you specifically to speak on that
item no in which case I'll go straight
to the recommendation that the council
resolves that option three as detailed
in paragraph four one of the officer
report be adopted to progress Local Plan
making in the short-term medium-term
subject to sufficient resources being
made available to facilitate this is
that a grave lenders thank you
I now move to item 9 on the agenda
report on urgent to sit decisions
there's none item 10 report of the
leader of the work of the Executive
Council a couple thank you very much
chairman chairman through you this is
the second ordinary council meeting of
the 2018-19 municipal year and i would
like to welcome all members since the
meeting on the 17th of july the
executive has met to endorse the
physical facilitation of a tourism forum
with a view to co-creation of the
discover 2020 festival and a tourism
strategy for oxford district noting the
tourism forum event on the 11th of
October 2018 and we've agreed the asset
disposal framework and aluminum to the
lease policy other matters that my
executive colleagues and I have dealt
with include approving the Environmental
Health Service plan for 2018 19 adopting
the corporate inclusion equality policy
and equality objectives 2018 to 21 as
well as the housing allocation policy
2018 and housing allocation policy short
guide confirming the article 4.1
Direction made by the council on the
19th of April 2018 submitting a formal
response to Castle Point Borough
Council's 2018 local plan consultation
noting that the authority monitoring
report 2016 18 will be published as part
of the council's evidence base for
planning as always chairman I will be
happy to take any questions from members
in respect of the work of the executive
and I'm sure my executive colleagues
will be happy to contribute where
appropriate thank you very much chairman
Thank You counsel counsel mr. Hoya
Thank You chairman it's only a brief
questioning Repat season the leader or
room
perhaps um and reduction is my latest on
this um I did attend the tourism forum
on the 11th October I did think it's
quite interesting and obviously there's
a lot of investment in office a time in
that event I know it's still fairly soon
after the event but I just wondered if
the council cut moreover engine options
how they felt the the event went and
whether or not it will be proved
fruitful Thank You chairman I thought it
was extremely good event I think there
was a very eclectic audience which
actually proves that it's very popular
throughout our district I think many of
our parishes and perhaps all our
parishes attended and took a very keen
interest in what was going on and it was
very interesting to hear all the
different things that were actually
coming out of that meeting things that
were coming out of the woodwork that we
didn't know about our own district and
some of the history and some of the
architecture and features that we you
know unique to Rockford we have a
fantastic history within our area I
think that's in our reflected in our
motto which is obviously our heritage
our future because we have we have an
eye to our heritage and you know there's
a lot to talk about you know we've been
here a long time Rochford we were
certainly here before south end which
was the south end of Britain well
originally and of course we had the
Tudor connection we have the smuggling
collection I'm pleased to say we've got
the connection with Darwin now etc and
of course we've got very great jewels
like the Wallasey wetlands you know
which is a fantastic development and the
thing that's coming forward so we've got
some real assets here we need to develop
well properly do them properly and we
need to celebrate properly as well the
church upper Ashington which is very
near to where I live
actually the Minster will be a thousand
years old in 2020 and that's quite
something so I think we really need to
celebrate these things and celebrate
them to make sure that local people as
well as people nearby know and put
Rochford really on the map and I think
that really helped to actually discuss
that and see how he can take it forward
can't do everything what I don't want is
one of
to drown out all the other events but
we'll take that forward I don't know if
you want to comment further at all thank
you Thank You chair yes there were over
50 separate so there were over 50
separate events and ideas that came out
of that particular session along with a
number of volunteers who agreed to give
up their time to be part of the
organizing committee I've been creating
the slides and the materials from RSPB
to put onto our website and I have in
draft two emails which will go out to
everybody following up from that meeting
which points them to those to the
website where more details our own
invites the the first meeting of the
organizing committee later on in into
November
in that case we'll move on to item 12
I'm sorry item 11 I missed that one
motions on notice there are none
item 12 remembers the purpose of this
report was to amend the arrangements for
the homelessness applications appeals
and the murder make the appearance than
the licensing committee together
the reason legislative changes imposed
by the housing reduction act 2017 has
provided an opportunity to reduce costs
and office officer time by joining the
two committees together 2017 act
introduced new measures which allowed
for a right to review at every new stage
this present would be impractical to
administer under the council's current
procedure whereby there is a discretion
step of an appeal the remaining
functions of the appeals committee
dealing with tax appeals and policies
and committee right to bid reviews can
be transferred to the licensing
committee for your information members
to date we have had no committee rights
of bid reviews and they have only been
to appeal meetings convened for taxes
this municipal year the second of which
is scheduled to take place next week on
the 6th of November so with this in mind
I recommend that the new structure comes
into effect on the 7th of November
chairman as well as the two
recommendations
I'm also seeking councils agreement to
amend the terms of reference to include
the current terms of reference for the
appeals committee with the addition of
reference to community rights of bid and
animal welfare licensing with the
wording as follows to exercise the
council's functions under the licensing
Act 2003 the gambling at 2005 and/or
associated or amending legislation to
exercise the council's functions in
relation to all appeals licensing and
registration as specified in schedule 1
to the local authorities functions and
responsibilities England regulations
2000 as amended the assets of community
value regulations 2012 and the animal
welfare licensing of activities
involving animals regulations 2019 Thank
You June
how's mrs. Weston thank chairman I was
going to ask that question about when
this committee will be set up you I've
noticed or understand your science so
November I do have a concern on that
because obviously we've got a lot of
experienced councils between the two
committees and people who sit on the
licensing committee have they had the
training on the appeal side does that
mean to say the protector set up a
training course very quickly in case any
appeals come through and and I
understand also you're just keeping the
number of members on the licensed
licensing committee for the appeals
committee combined together you're not
going to add any more members can you
just confirm thank you
so chairman the new licensing appeal
committee will be 15 members as the
licensing committees now training is
will be provided to all members
especially with the new animal welfare
licensing legislation that's in my
offices at the moment are in the process
of training themselves so we're waiting
for guidance from central governments
come through as soon as that sir we will
provide training I don't anticipate
there to be any Appeals at the moment
because we're still we're still
receiving new applications so what's the
second question
so I come in company as I asked
animal welfare training I don't know
just the appeals training no you said
about the training yeah Appeals training
will be given to all members I come back
on that
so obviously appeals committee is gonna
be dysfunctional is it's not gonna be a
the people's committee is gonna be no
longer it's gonna go into the or their
licensing commit you're gonna take on it
appeals my other question is why we do
why are we doing it so earlier than
November why can we not wait til later
on maybe beginning and make sure that
was the only question really I think
there prior to here is because of the
new you're homeless reduction act
legislation so that needs to be amended
quite quickly to take into account the
new Act
our current procedures do not you know
it does not know it's not practical to
administer than you under the new Act
the remaining functions as I explained I
mean members I chairman I'm guide very
if you want to wait till the new
municipal year possibly but I don't
think that would be highly practical
because there's not been that many
reviews or appeals as such anyway I mean
this is something we can we can consider
do we have a proposer on that
well chairman ah I'm listening to the
discussion I think my question
essentially is what would be the risk
factor to the council if we were to
postpone this action till the start of
the new municipal yeah obviously into
next year because they it does seem that
the necessary training is going to be
somewhat of a clamor to organize and I
think the practicality of rearranging
the committee's as well is is perhaps an
unfortunate exercise to have to go
through so if if we could have comment
on the actual risk factor to the council
and attempt to quantify that and then
dependent on that that that answer I
might be happy to propose that we
postpone this to the start of the new
moon municipal yeah thank you chairman
the main risk factor would be with
regards to the homeless reduction act
procedure because of the new reviews
that's coming in every stage at present
our current procedures allow for extra
an extra discretionary step which is not
in line with legislation so it's out of
step with the current legislation so I
think that that would be a risk the
homeless know side of things with
regards to taxi licensing and community
work two bits as I search em and I'm
open to perhaps if to consider well it's
really move members of members would
like the appeals committee to remain in
place just to deal with the taxi and the
community right to bid side but have
their homeless reduction at homelessness
reviews taken out of it with the media
effect
I hope coughs mr. Hoyer on this
particular subject okay Thank You
chairman a couple of questions maybe it
might be relevant to this as well I
don't have a problem with the peels and
licensing being combined perhaps but
counsel mrs. weston's point about
training and experience members there's
nothing to prevent group leaders
changing the membership of the licensure
committee it is exactly stop them
putting people who are experiencing
appeals onto it now they can do that at
any time and that takes effect
immediately
nothing you see five or six members of
appeals I've just written for the court
meant already so I don't think that
would be a problem I think there is an
issue around training I'll probably
approve that to some extent to get the
remaining members trained up
sufficiently because there are pills
beef there are three or four members on
there who are experienced them in the
fields already that shouldn't be a
problem I think my concern however is
still still comes back to the day of 7th
of November which is the date you sign
that change to take place on the problem
is this isn't within the Constitution
yet so how is if this committee isn't
constitutional the Constitution hasn't
been approved with these changes and it
can't be are assumed before the December
meeting unless we have an extraordinary
meeting so I don't know if that how
legal aids can we have a an answer on
the legality of a committee which isn't
within the Constitution thank you I've
been assured by my colleague as you
can't be done so sorry could you just
repeat that question chairman of it and
as the committee is not within the
Constitution they are separate
committees is that this would this be
legal with this it was there be I I have
a lot of problems recently integrate I
raised the licensing on another point
words I find it very important and if we
have a committee which here's an appeal
which isn't within our Constitution
would that make the Appeal decision null
and void don't have concerns over that
the decision or tonight's council will
be what is me is what is introducing
this new committee as I've said with the
term new terms of reference within the
Constitution Constitution chairman if
Council agrees to adjust one of its
committees and the arrangements
associated in terms of terms of
reference then whenever the council's
decide council decides that takes effect
from the Constitution will be adjusted
to show the new arrangement chairman I'd
like to propose if we put it back to May
next year for the discussions that have
gone this evening all I want to be a
seconder on that place thank you
seconder
you're seconding that thank you in that
case the motion before us is to defer
before we proceed to that perhaps miss
ball can give us some advice sure I
would like just some guidance with
regards to the homelessness appeal side
things are we deferring the whole item
to make because if you do that will mean
deferring changing the homelessness
review process which will impacts on
your housing officers currently dealing
with the reviews
chairman sorry I'm still concerned with
we're pushing this too too quick sorry I
just need some more information you say
about the homelessness act I mean how
much how many homeless
you said law offices tell I'm I'm asking
you a big question as opposed now how
many homeless is are we going to be
looking at and the next sort of we're
advised that the if we if the motion
that you've put forward includes the
homelessness situation then we would be
subject to some difficulty now one
option of course opens use if you're
minded to exclude from your motion the
reference to the homelessness the
homelessness reviews
excuse-excuse me chairman and my onions
and my own you understand you that one
of the committees can do with the
homelessness at the moment if that comes
well if that comes up between now when I
make oh can I can I allow a counselor
cup water speak he's been waiting for
quite patiently to do so so chairman is
to help out hopefully offices and they
have our colleagues as well but I
propose that perhaps we amend our
proposal to the seventh of November to
next May but as far as and I think what
the officer is suggesting is as far as
the homelessness legislation is
concerned that indeed that actually
moves over to the licensing committee
with the appropriate training where
appropriate and then the actual whole
thing is consolidated from next May so
you're actually moving over the other
two things but not the homelessness side
and hopefully that would satisfy the
legislation as well as our members thank
you chairman sorry chairman just for
clarity the homelessness won't be moving
anywhere that the the review stay with
offices in accordance with the current
legislation so we are not moving the
homelessness reviews anywhere currently
the homeless reviews are a discretion
step that our council have that no other
council hands that is not in line with
legislation
get down for mrs. question uh would you
be happy with energy sorry chairman yes
I think I think we'll be happy with that
and you be happy with that
Smith castor Smith you're happy with
that and I don't know if this this
complicates the situation but but but
the recommendation that's in front of in
front of members is one that the policy
of providing an intermediary appeal
route to the appeals committee is
discontinued so it seems to me that that
that is exactly what is being said that
that intermedia route is is deleted from
the appeals committee in terms of the
second recommendation that the licensing
committee absorbs the functions of the
appeals committee and is renamed or
licensing an appeals committee the
membership of which is the same as the
current licensing committee well but the
latter part of that sentence would be
subject to what what council determined
in a tan your council in in me but but
what needs to be added to that
recommendation is is that that that that
is approved and becomes operational in
me
sorry can I can I come back again on the
recommendation what we're saying then we
can approve number one and and put back
number two yeah thank you very much can
I propose that sorry so that you're
amending your amending your proposal and
you're you're seconding of that as
amended
did you want to speak I thought you had
your hand oh it's no thank you chairman
thank you
contra Mountain Thank You chairman just
a slight bit of clarification we are
amending point two until May for what
purpose
correct what's what's going to happen
between now and and and may what why is
it being deferred until May
oh sorry chairman I either train in
which obviously is essential and
clarification of what's obviously need
you to required on that on that on the
Constitution and someone else said one
counts are said can we hear that for
clarity counsel mrs. Western what
exactly is now being proposed sorry
it's a training on the second one is
really to do with the training right so
we are saying I forgive me if let me
just confirm if I have this correctly
understood part one of the proposal that
the policy of providing an intermediary
appeal route to the appeals committee is
discontinued and that is forthwith and
the paragraph two that the functions of
the appeals and licensing committees etc
that's deferred until May
presumably until the next municipal year
so just for clarification the the
implementation of the new committee
would be in in May but in principle the
council is agreeing this evening that
the two committees would be amalgamated
Thank You mr. chairman there seems to be
quite a lot of confusion and I think it
comes from the amalgamation and the
proposal there's no dating there in the
report which was unhelpful the 7th of
November I can understand the concern
there but the reasoning and the logic
for this amalgamation was to save costs
and to save officer time so we've we've
worked two issues one was training which
councillor Hawaii has very ably pointed
out we have members that are trained and
the membership of committees is up to
the group leaders so that can be
accommodated the other issue that I
think hasn't been very well clarified
tonight is the Constitution well so we
can actually agree to a change of
Constitution we also need the detail
because it affects more than one part of
the Constitution as I'm sure everyone
knows certainly our officers should know
and I would I accept what councilor
Western the concern that you have and I
do think it should be deferred but not
until May I think it should be deferred
until the next full council meeting we
agree in principle but we need to see
the alterations to the Constitution as
alterations to the Constitution have to
come before full council before they can
be adopted so therefore we need that the
alterations to the Constitution to be
added to this report so that we can
agree the two things together otherwise
you've got an agreement that can't
properly be implemented
so certainly I would say defer till next
full council or if the debt so I would
propose that amendment if councilor
Weston is happy with that and then there
also allows for any training secondly
may present thank you but there's been
mr. Mason will you just tell me exactly
what you're proposing now what I'm
proposing is that tonight we agree
imprint with rights and one I think is
great so I meant them to that we agree
in principle the licensing committee
will absorb the function of the appeals
committee and will be renamed the
licensing and appeals committee with
effect from the next full council when
the alteration to the Constitution would
also put to full kept but be put to full
council so that that can be adopted at
the same time so that we have our
Constitution and our actions in line and
the training schedule can be drawn up if
necessary in the time is fine that that
gives plenty of time for that to be done
although I don't think this great deal
of need for training but if there is it
can be done in that time frame thank you
is that clear
do we have a seconder to that proposal
we've had a second for you you second it
thank you
in that case beyond we need to vote on
the amendment unless anybody wants to
speak to the amendment first councilor
cap move well chairman we've already got
a proposal to do it from a I can't see a
problem with that we're not talking
about a great deal of funding here and I
think it's something that the status quo
will carry on and I see no reason why we
can't do that in my I don't see what see
what the hurry is frankly so let's let's
carry on with the original budget I
think I think they did the difficulty is
deciding what we're going to vote upon
because we have been advised that the
legislative reasons okay Canterbury's
thank you but the same reasoning of a
leader I can't see any reason being why
we can't actually defer just until the
next council
casual hook way Thank You chairman I'm
having net listen to the discussions and
the debate around this matter it would
seem that councillor Mason's
proposal would be the most practical and
sensible and logical way forward thank
you so chairman first of all you've got
an amendment to the original motion that
and and the the effect the the mb
amendment is is firstly as with the
original motion that the recommendation
one in the report stands that the policy
providing an intermediary appear route
be discontinued and secondly that the
absorption of the licensure committee
with the functions of the appeals
committee and its renaming be deferred
to the next meeting of full council to
provide for a report showing what the
Constitution would look like and any
training implications
that's the amendment chairman that
wasn't exactly what I said I didn't say
it was deferred I said it was agreed in
principle tonight the implementation to
take place at next full council with the
changes necessary changes to the
Constitution I wasn't trying to defer
the decision defer the implementation
thank you it seems to me though that if
if if you're you're saying we need to
change to the Constitution we can't
agree it in principle because that would
be outside the Constitution so it's a
point of order we can agree to change
from a future day we can agree in
principle what we agreeing is that the
full thing will be done on in December
I'm sorry I disagree with here in that
case we'll bill will put to the vote the
amended did you want to speak chasm a
mountain
sorry Thank You chairman just it's in
relation to councilor cut Moore's
comments the the reason that I'm in
favor of the amendment is because the
wording of the recommendation as is is
isn't clear and and the answer to my
question why wasn't really answered in
the wording that was presented counselor
mrs. Mason came up with an amendment
which I think covers those questions and
that's why I will support the amendment
thank you so item 2 then is going to be
deferred until the next council meeting
Thank You chairman so you're now looking
for a vote in favor of the amendment
excuse me chairman please
council mrs. Mason for the avoidance of
doubt and absolute clarity will you
please indicate exactly what is your
amendment so we can vote on it yes
certainly I'm happy to assist the
council mr. chairman in that respect as
there seems to be I'm told to confusion
that that the licensing committee will
so this is a policy will absorb the
functions of the appeals committee and
will be renamed the licensing and
appeals committee I don't think we need
the comment on membership with effect
from the next full council meeting when
the changes to the Constitution will
also be presented to a full council and
to allow for training to be implemented
in the interim where necessary thank you
with all those who are voting in favor
of that amendment raise their hands that
there's against
the amendment is lost so we now go to
the original motion as its as it is
written in the report Germany the
original motion is about report
recommendation one being agreed and
report recommendation two being put in
place with effect from the beginning of
the next municipal year all those in
favor please raise their hands those
against
with all you ask you yes that's fine yep
okay right that's the end of that item
that recommendation was approved we now
go to item 13 Aaron this report proposes
to adopt the new arrangements in
relation to the animal welfare licensing
of activities involving animal
regulations 2018 in light of the new
regulations the report sets out the
proposed delegation of powers and the
new fee structure which is based which
is been calculated and cost recovery
basis finally it also seeks authority to
be dedicated to the CRS a licensing an
appeals committee to approve the
amendments to the policy in relation to
any new regulations coming through
thereafter in response to a member query
received today the 2018 regulations only
cover the following licensable
activities the selling of animals as
pets providing or arranging for the
provision of boarding for cats or dogs
hiring out horses breeding of dogs
keeping or training animals for
exhibitions and for clarity in relation
to penalties it is an offense to breach
any of the license conditions or to not
comply with an inspectors requests or
drops and inspector on their inspections
this could result with an unlimited fine
anyone who carries out any licensable
activities without a license would be
liable to imprisonment for a term of six
months fine or both
any illegal activity that amounts to
cruelty to animals are covered under the
Animal Welfare Act mr. chairman
recommendation for this report is on
page thirteen point four
to resolve to approve any amendments to
the policy in relation sorry that the
authority to approve any amendments to
the policy in relation to animal welfare
licensing would you like me to repeat
this Bruce so chairman and I start from
the beginning would you like me to start
from beginning more carry on so a
chairman the recommendations are that
authority to approve any amendments to
the policy in relation to animal welfare
licensing of activities involving
animals the regulations be dedicated to
the licensing and appeals committee the
authority be delegated for granting
refusing renewing varying suspending or
revoking licenses under the animal
welfare licensing or activities
involving animals regulations 218 on the
basis are set out under paragraph 3.1 of
this report and that the licensing fee
schedule appended to the report be
adopted Thank You chairman thank you
does anybody have any questions cast
mrs. Macpherson Thank You chairman I
just don't think I can say and thank you
to the officer for the report this is a
very important report and I was quite
saddened that people did want to check
through it but thank you officer
yeah Thank You chairman
just a quick item just if you could
clarify this for me the report refers to
renewing of licenses but um in appendix
one all it actually says is application
fees the application fees the same as
renewal fees I'm assuming there will be
a fee for renewing licenses but that's
not actually set out or define
so chairman these these are application
fees is what it will be
it does include renewal fees so
application stroke renewal fees
characterization Thank You mr. chair
just a very small point when the officer
read out the proposal one she said the
licensing and appeals committee we've
just determined that we either have a
licensing or an appeals committee and
the recommendation in writing says
licensing committee so I assume that the
recommendation is as written perhaps you
would clarify their chairman and at the
time writing the report there was just
enough seats in committee perhaps we
should amend it to licensing an appeals
committee
yeah I think we should we just amend the
recommendations sorry mr. chairman it
obviously misunderstood again it's
delegated to the licensing committee I
have no problem whatsoever with the
recommendation it was the fact that she
actually read out something that wasn't
there
thank you
we just as member
no it's for his children because you
have this this will to be as fine as it
is
I'm advised that it is perfectly okay
because the change won't take effect
until the next community civil year mr.
chairman that is exactly what I was
pointing out but unfortunately when the
officer read out verbally she said
licensing and appeals committee I see so
that was you know perhaps perhaps if my
apologies if I did after the last I
thought I thought you were referring to
this believe it as it is counselor mr.
Mason so thank you thank you and this
councillor McPherson says this is our
really important a set of measures that
is being put in place the officer spoke
about the penalties that can be exact
upon people who breached these licensing
conditions can I ask what procedures
what process the council will have in
inspecting these facilities to ensure
that all licensing and lawful activities
are undertaken in accordance with all of
the regulations that are set out
chairman the offices carry out upon any
renewal and application inspections in
the first place they they will carry out
throughout the year regular checks on
them and this is a new licensing regime
for the animal welfare side of things
they will for certain inspections they
do require vet to be present so they
have engaged with local vets to do that
this is fairly new and it's almost
almost a second see as to how we go so
to embed the new procedures we don't
actually have a set regime as yet as to
how often and how much but we'd also
rely on the public's who helped tip us
off on any illegal activities German
obviously tipping off I'd rather call
allegations until proven it's it's
criminal offence for dealing with here
I'm a little concerned that the council
hasn't actually got any procedures yet
to actually undertake inspections and
more particularly how we're going to
follow up appropriately on matters that
are subject to allegation from the
public or other people and also we
haven't got a clue
it seems again what costs are going to
be incurred by the council is there a
budget the fees that we charge are based
on cost recovery basis which takes into
account the management of the licensing
at the license fees and any enforcement
issues those fees will be renewed
annually at present this is a new fee
schedule so we won't we will have to
with the finance team review that and
see if we are charging the right costs
okay I know oh sorry mr. Griffin Thank
You chairman southend-on-sea bar
accounts or have a an animal warden um
do we have a similar person or can we
call on the services of another council
at or Jim I'm not here so what the
unwalled and dozens out then we have
licensing officers cone out the
inspections and they're trained to carry
out those inspections okay thank you
very much
I've arty recommendations agreed agreed
item and I'll ask thank you is Tim I'll
charlie brief the report sets out to
seek approval earth the appointment of
Southend Borough Council to undertake
improvement scheme and the cost of a
hundred eighty four thousand to the car
park and actors at Cherry Orchard
Country Park the report sets out the
sort of them or the detail the
recommendation is that one hundred four
thousand pound contract the car park
extension and new access route at Cherry
Orchard Jubilee Country Park the award
to self in Borough Council and that nine
thousand pound is drawn down from the
hard soft infrastructure reserve its
makeup bounties that required for the
above works thank you are there any
questions
council Wilson thank you I wasn't sure
whether you will see they will make
thank chairman I'm not against this
proposal in principle I'd like to have a
couple of questions answered and the
first is at paragraphs two point two of
the report we've got the scope of the
project we've been 480 car parking
spaces and my first question is that at
paragraph three slowly we're proposing
that we're going to spend an extra nine
thousand pounds have we considered one
of these spending extra money actually
restricted in the skull in other words
having less parking spaces that that's
question one and second one is that
paragraph three point so we talked about
the benefits of transparency of having
South in Borough Council do this but
again I I don't have a problem with that
at all but my question is have we been
shot in other words has South in Borough
Council cut the road margin on this and
are we confident that that's actually
less than it would cost us to run the
exercise in half we prepared it in-house
and my final question really is just a
question at paragraph 4.1 we're saying
that if we if there's a delay of
approximately 12 weeks we would have to
run our own competitive tender I just
like to know what that 12 weeks is why
why would we have to run a competitive
tender if we run over the toilet thank
you
so thank you first one yes we could cut
the cloth to try and reduce the size of
the car pump but if he comes a little
bit of a sort of a back and forth
process we're not careful so 80 spaces
it was a neat design if that makes sense
you're gonna start trying to trim down
one two three or four spaces the
additional cost is not so much in the
design of the car park so actually the
cost came in slightly under it was a
additional work such as a high barrier
and fencing around the edge so so many
ways I felt that it was best to keep
with that design on the second on the
second issue in terms of transparency
know there are there are no additional
costs so I've actually seen the cost of
quality by their contractor so that we
are paying directly if you like in that
sense I guess in much of their interest
to see is delivered as part of the
airport scheme as it is us so they're
there they're willing to to assist in
this matter on the third one the 12-week
is very much an estimate so call so is a
procurement process so the present to
clear that will be a part of the
competitive tender process so that we
there are 12 exceeds us putting their
tails so that it's not and then the
competitive process that daddy's a
competitive tender prices we ask taken
the twelve weeks with regards to the
initial cluster that we've been
allocated to are going to the s106 can
you explain to me how that figure was
arrived at and I've been presuming that
this was an allocation specifically for
the car park in the first place and why
we may need that with the short form
thank you it's a necklace at the time so
you know and I'll be truthful with with
the sort of the the work so you're
talking that I think is a short that's
that's quite reasonable I mean it's an
estimate based off you know an 80 space
car park with
very rough plans so it's what you can
expect the prices have to shift slightly
with topography surveys and the like
so in many ways I'm quite pleased with
the estimate and what we've done is we
said actually there's a bit of
additional work here pretty wasn't
considered and that it's mainly the
height barriers and and some of the sort
of fencing down the edges but I'm so
part of the pricing is pretty spot-on it
just concerns me that if we've got the
opportunity within s106 agreements but
you won't raise the right figure
historically recently it seems to me
that a lot of the budgets that are being
put to s106 function
would it not actually be something that
we could be looking to maybe be a little
bit more realistic
knowing that prices always go up and
that we would be looking to do things in
a few years in advance to be a little
bit nearer the figures that really need
to fund these projects I think usually
termed a contribution so in many sense
it's down to the it's down to the
individual negotiations for each one so
I wasn't privy to the exact ago she
ations of these contribution so whether
it should be a hundred percent or not
ease is I guess down to to the merits of
that individual planning application and
the conditions that are imposed so I you
know almost pronounce on my remit what
you're asking but in many ways I felt
that was you know a good a good price
we've gone I said what we've done is
actually did put on some additional
works on setting the same time so things
like the Highbury pretty we've never
been a part of that negotiation ad I
mean these in our interest as well to
have this car park so I think there's
always views as a contribution that to
some extent so the second we managed to
use that funding to almost a hundred
cents on that car park is probably a
good thing
okay unless there are any other
questions counsel cuttable
german through you i'm very pleased to
see that this is coming forward and i'm
very pleased to see that we've actually
got virtually the whole contribution
towards the car park and the works that
are being proposed
I think we're getting them an extremely
reasonable price I think the officers
said now about three times the fact that
the difference in the price is about the
the fencing and the height barrier etc
so we're actually getting the money for
the car part we're getting the money for
the alterations and we're getting it for
free chairman because it's part of the
106 agreement that's done so I think
it's far as the negotiation of 106
agreements is concern is absolutely spot
on and I don't see what the problem is
so I myself I'm very pleased that we're
going to get this facility for Cherry
Orchard I think it will make a real
difference to the access to the park
because you've got a proper roundabout
that takes it forward and I really am
pleased to support it thank you Jim
thank you in that case I shall now
thank you
thank you there to greet their members
thank you that being the last item on
the agenda those meeting at 9:48 14
members please be upstanding as a
chairman and manager director leave the
chamber
[Music]
you